نعم محمد ولعلي سانطي من هذه التطورات في
المنطقه الوسطى نذكر بان هذه التطورات
التي ذكرت قبل قليل في المنطقه الوسطى
تاتي وحينما ننظر الى هذه الخريطه المجمله
بينما كان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد اعلن عن
اعاده او عن توسيع وتعميق عمليته في
المنطقه الجنوبيه اي في تحديدا في خان
يونس وتاتي هذه التطورات بينما اوك للفرقه
رقم 99 العمل على مستوى المنطقه الوسطى
بينما اكدت للفرقه رقم 162 العمل في
المناطق الشماليه لكن المنطقه الوسطى
اليوم تصنع الحدث بهذا الخبر حينما نذهب
الى تفاصيل الصوره فالامر يتعلق بما تم
الاعلان عنه نذكر باننا كنا امس قد تحدثنا
عن عمليه قصف مكثفه لمناطق الوسطى وتحديدا
في منطقه المغازي والمناطق التي تفصل
المنطقه الوسطى عن المناط المناطق
الشماليه من المنطقه الجنوبيه وتحديدا بين
الجراره والمغازي هذا القصف ياتي بينما تم
تداول اخبار عن حادث جلل هنا في المغازي
بالنسبه لجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تحدث عن
عن مقتل نحو 21 جنديا وضابطا في منطقه
المغازي تحت قرب منطقه المغازي في بينما
كان هؤلاء يحاولون تفخيخ مبنيين في منطقه
تبعد نحو 600 من السياج الفاصل ربما ياتي
ذلك بينما كان ايضا هناك استهداف لمنطقه
المصدر ليس هذا الاستهداف هو الاول ولكن
المصدر كانت تعرضت الى عمليه قصف مكثفه
وذلك في اكثر من مره اذا المنطقه الوسطى
سواء متعلق بمخيم المغازي او الزوايده او
بالتاكيد مخيم البريج هذا المخيم الذي
تابعنا عمليات القصف المكثفه وللمفارقة
او انفجار لشاحنه وادت الى اصابه نحو 30
جنديا قبل ايام وتحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي
على ان ذلك تم بسبب عمليه قصف خاطئه
لدبابه اسرائيليه لهذه الشاحنه اذا تطورات
لافته على مستوى مخيمات المنطقه الوسطى
التي تعرضت الى عمليات قصف مكثفه طله
اسابيع في محاوله ايضا لفصل هذه المنطقه
خصوصا هذه المخيمات الاربعه البريج
النصيرات الزوايده والمغازي عن دير البل
التي بدورها كانت محور قصف مكثف للقوات
قوات الجيش جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الحديث عن عمليه استهداف المنطقه
تحديدا تحديدا استهداف هذا المبنيين في
منطقه المغازي ياتي بينما كان للمقاومه
ايضا اداء خلال الاسابيع القادمه من خلال
استهداف اليات اسرائيليه عبر هذه المحاور
سواء في البريج او سواء ايضا في مخيم
المغازي وتحديدا ايضا في المصدر تاتي هذه
التطورات دون ان نهمل الحديث عن التطورات
المقابله في المنطقه الجنوبيه منطقه خان
يونس من خلال عمليه قصف مكثفه وتناولنا
العاجل المتعلق بعمليه قصف خصوصا في
المناطق الغربيه وايضا الشماليه الغربيه
من خان يونس بينما تدور اشتباكات عنيفه في
وسط او في وسط خانيونس تحديدا في هذه
الاماكن المفصله حينما نذهب الى هذه
الخريطه نحن نتحدث عن مجموعه من المحاور
نتحدث عن مستشفى ناصر نتحدث عن مستشفى
الامل وايضا هذه الاماكن التي تمركزت لا
نقول امامها ولكن بعيدا عنها نوعا ما
خصوصا مستشفى ناصر تمركز الدبابات
اسرائيليه في محاوله للتوغل ضمن ما اعلنه
الجيش الاسرائيلي عن عمليه توسيع وتعميق
لعمليته نذكر باننا كلما كان هناك حدث
متعلق بخسائر للجيش الاسرائيلي يكثف من
عمليات قصفه واستهدافه ربما لتشتيت الصوره
بينما الحدث الرئيسي كما تابعنا جاءنا من
المنطقه الوسطى محمد ش